mitten im Krieg ist ein Team von
ukrainischen sonderermittlern auf dem
Weg in den Osten des Landes auf der Spur
eines Verbrechens über das die meisten
lieber schweigen Vergewaltigungen
nur ein Dorf das gerade erst befreit
wurde fünf Monate lang hatten die Russen
den Ort besetzt langsam erst trauen die
Menschen sich wieder auf die Straße
Ermittler missiak hat Lebensmittel
mitgebracht für die Menschen die oft
völlig isoliert waren
zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte
ermitteln wir Kriegsverbrechen und
sexuelle Gewalt nicht am Ende eines
Krieges sondern während der militärische
Konflikt noch andauert
und seine Kollegin Irina samborska sind
verabredet mit der Bürgermeisterin des
Dorfes von ihr möchten die Ermittler
wissen ob es Fälle von Vergewaltigungen
gegeben hat
das waren Männer von der sogenannten
Volksrepublik sie haben diese Verbrechen
verübt ich weiß nicht wie die Menschen
das ausgehalten haben
auch wenn die ukrainische Armee die kon
über das Dorf zurück hat wie so oft
stoßen die Ermittler auch hier auf einem
Mauer des Schweigens die Angst dass die
Russen wieder zurückkehren die Scham
über das Erlebte zu sprechen herrscht
vor und bei vielen auch der Wunsch zu
vergessen
Irina dorfgang will gegen das Schweigen
kämpfen sie selbst wurde 2014 in ihrer
Heimatstadt von russischen Soldaten
vergewaltigt
[Musik]
es war der Beginn des Krieges gegen die
Ukraine russische Soldaten Söldner und
ukrainische Separatisten eroberten die
Stadt und er richteten einen
Terror-Regime in dem Vergewaltigung und
Folter schon damals an der Tagesordnung
waren
mit ihrem Mann und ihren Kindern kann
Irina bis heute nicht darüber sprechen
was sie erlebte sie hat eine
Selbsthilfeorganisationen gegründet um
Opfer zu unterstützen in Butcher will
sie eine der Frauen besuchen die ihre
Geschichte erzählen möchte
erzähl einmal als sie kamen das war
beängstigend oder
als sie kamen bin ich auf meine Knie
gefallen und habe gepfleht bitte tut das
nicht tötet mich bitte nicht
aber er hat geschrien zieh dich aus ich
hatte noch Bluse und Unterhose an
er ist meine Bluse und Unterwäsche von
meinem Körper
er fuhr mit seiner Waffe über meinen
Körper steckte sie zwischen meine Beine
ich dachte er wird mich töten
Klaus Hoffmann hat solche Aussagen oft
gehört die Geschichten ähneln sich den
Menschen ihr Mensch sein nehmen das sei
das Ziel vor 20 Jahren hat er bereits an
der Ermittlung von Kriegsverbrechen im
ehemaligen Jugoslawien mitgearbeitet
seit März 2022 berät er die Ukraine sind
die Vergewaltigungen Einzelfälle wie
zunächst einige internationale
Organisationen behauptet hatten
insgesamt zeigt aber die Masse an
Verbrechen dass das nicht Einzeltaten
sind oder Zufallszahlen sind sondern
spricht sehr viel dafür dass das ganze
System hat und zumindest so weit System
hat dass eben die Taten der Soldaten
durch die Führungsebene geduldet wenn
ich da ermutigt werden dazu
in Butcher wird zum ersten Mal das
Ausmaß der Verbrechen deutlich russische
Soldaten hinterlassen im März 2022 eine
Stadt in der sie gemordet gefoltert und
vergewaltigt haben die Opfer sind nicht
nur ältere Frauen es sind auch Männer
und Kinder das jüngste bekannte Opfer
ist vier Jahre alt
wurde in einem Internierungslager in
Donezk festgehalten Folter
Vergewaltigungen bis zu Kastrationen
mussten die Inhaftierten erdulden
berichtet er
die Täter hätten seine Genitalien mit
Elektroschocks verletzt
[Musik]
sie haben mich mit Elektroschocks
gequält sie auch in meinen Anus
eingeführt sie haben gedroht mich zu
töten dann haben sie mich gezwungen
Oralsex mit anderen Männern zu machen
auch Irina dorfgon wurde in einem
Folterkeller gefangen gehalten bis sie
schließlich fliehen konnte neun Jahre
ist es her dass sie in Don jetzt von
russischen Soldaten vergewaltigt wurde
heute betreibt sie einen Kosmetiksalon
in Kiew ihre Würde als Frau habe man ihr
für immer genommen erzählt sie doch
einer von ihnen hat gesagt sie würden
mich nicht direkt töten weil das was
dokt Bataillon von jasnovata zurückkäme
und ich würde für Ihre Entspannung zur
Verfügung stehen müssen
für die gesamte Armee
weil sie sich nach den militärischen
Manövern entspannen müssten danach
würden sie mich in einem Wald verscharen
meine Familie würde mich nie wieder
sehen
[Musik]
viele der Opfer der Vergewaltigungen
sind tot das erschwert die Ermittlungen
zusätzlich dennoch sieht Klaus Hoffmann
eine Chance dass die Verbrechen eines
Tages zur Anklage kommen
aber nicht nur das für den immer wieder
in die Ukraine zurück ich fühle mit den
Menschen hier mit den Opfern und ich
glaube wir versuchen einfach mit unserer
Arbeiter im kleinen Beitrag zu leisten
die Wahrheit ans Licht zu bringen und in
einem gewissen Umfang den Opfern
Gerechtigkeit zu verschaffen gehört zu
schaffen dass ihre Geschichte erzählt
wird und dass sie nicht in Vergessenheit
gerät
es braucht viel Geduld das spüren auch
Viktor und Irina an diesem Tag haben sie
erst einmal versucht Vertrauen zu
schaffen sie werden noch einmal
zurückkehren sie wissen viele Menschen
brauchen Zeit um in Worte zu fassen was
fassungslos macht dass die Täter eines
Tages zur Verantwortung gezogen werden
in der Ukraine oder vor einem
internationalen Strafgericht dafür
wollen sie weiterarbeiten
[Musik]